une situation épidémique préoccupante en
russie en danger à cause du variant
delta pour le quatrième jour consécutif
le pays a enregistré un record de décès
en 24 heures 6 179 morts le plus lourd
bilan depuis l'apparition de la pandémie
ciel à les détails depuis moscou d'un
autre cause pendante revers à kaufmann
il n'est pas question de confinement
déclaré le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov
il a appelé la population russe à se
faire vacciner le plus vite possible
afin d'éviter justement le retour aux
restrictions les plus drastiques écouté
personne ne veut de confinement il n'est
pas question de confinement voilà
pourquoi pour qu'il n'en soit pas
question il faut se faire vacciner
nous devons tous nous faire vacciner le
plus vite possible parce qu en même
temps subi une augmentation exclusif des
cas de coronavirus les capacités de la
ville ne suffisent plus la maire
adjointe de la capitale nastassia
hirakova affirme que les autorités sont
obligées de mobiliser de plus en plus
depuis tôt pour faire face à la pandémie
d'abord nous avons réorienté nos
hôpitaux
dès que la première vague de la pandémie
s'est calmé nous avons commencé à
construire des hôpitaux de réserve
il est clair que maintenant quand nous
constatons une augmentation exploser des
cas de la maladie ses capacités ne
suffisent plus il est pour une courte
période j'espère vivement que ce n'est
que pour une courte période
nous mobilisons à nouveau d'autres
hôpitaux dans le cadre de la lutte
contre ce virus y d'oubli nous savons
qu'en été le volume des autres soins
médicaux diminue légèrement
j'espère que dès que le taux de
contamination diminuera ses hôpitaux
retrouverons immédiatement leur
fonctionnement normal
mais nous garderons xi capacité de
réserve qui nous permettent de faire
face dans un premier temps à n'importe
quel taux de contamination la directrice
de l' agence fédérale rospotrebnadzor
anneaux popova explique la situation
actuelle par la propagation du variante
delta ii coronavirus selon elle même si
chaque nouvelle souche est plus forte
que la précédente
il s'agit toujours du même virus le
virus delta a touché jusqu'à 90 p -o
il s'est rapidement propagé dans le
monde et il est en train de remplacer la
souche britannique mais il faut dire que
lorsqu'en décembre dernier la souche
britannique est apparue elle a
rapidement remplacé à celle de roi à
laquelle on était déjà habitué dans un
grand nombre de pays maintenant la
nouvelle c'est le processus de
l'évolution du virus
bien sûr chaque nouvelle version
apparaît pour faire en sorte que la
mutation consolidé lui permettent de
2009 la population
chaque nouvelle souche est plus forte
que la précédente modifié de façon à ce
qu'elles touchent de plus en plus de
gens les en même temps il s'agit
toujours du même virus on s'est rarement
le de 23000 de nouveaux cas de
coronavirus ont été détectés en russie
en dernières 24 heures donc presque 7000
à moscou le nombre des décès monté
jusqu'à 679 dans le pays
c'est le maximum depuis le début de la
pandémie